am I the kind of [ __ ] who would grow
this five o'clock shadow for a week and
dress up like this just for the intro
and thumbnail of his video nope not at
all so I'm gonna wear this for the
entire video why it's very simple cuz
I'm a fan
Metal Gear Solid three songs in the game
just being legit I look like al-qaeda as
right try to look like the epitome of
Cold War America end up looking like
al-qaeda sorry America little Gear Solid
3 Snake Eater it takes place in 1964
during the Cold War and you play as
snake that's right it's a different
snake it's not Solid Snake from Metal
Gear Solid Metal Gear Solid 2 then you
realize you're like wait a minute
do I please big boss in his prime and
you do this is the origin story of not
just Metal Gear but big boss he's
already a badass soldier but doesn't
even have the eyepatch yet you see how
he loses his eye how he gets the title
big boss this is it my friends this is
the genesis so Metal Gear Solid 3 Snake
Eater it's actually a couple missions
wrapped up in one the first mission you
go on is called the virtuous missions at
the very beginning of the game it's the
intro kind of like the tanker scene in
Metal Gear Solid 2 you gotta go get this
scientist who's working on something for
the Russians called war so of course
it's gonna be America and Russia but
then come to find out this isn't really
a spoiler because it's in the intro of
the game the very first Prelude mission
this is every bit as much of a spoiler
as saying that the tanker sinks in Metal
Gear Solid 2 is a spoiler it's not as
really a spoiler your mentor known as
the boss a hero of World War 2 has
defected to the Soviet Union she kicks
your ass she goes off with the bad guys
and you get this James Bondish intro ice
then you go back in operation
Snake Eater in which your mission is to
eliminate the boss and it's not just
like oh she defected got to take her out
there are logistics involved in it you
know those espionage type things in
which the Soviet Union also wants you to
do it some of the things I love about
this game it's a very involved plot
taking place on the Cold War so that's
always cool so we're going to jump right
into the gameplay of Metal Gear Solid 3
Snake Eater the gameplay quite frankly
is just the perfect Metal Gear Solid
game plan it's like all those advances
that they had in Metal Gear Solid 2
still had some flaws in it flaws that I
addressed in my review of Metal Gear
Solid 2 but in Snake Eater they were
like alright let's just iron out all the
bugs perfected all the advances we made
from Metal Gear Solid 1 to two are now
perfected in two to three first of all
there's no solace in radar
you know that little radar on the top
right of the screen that shows where the
enemies are and where their field of
vision is it's pretty much like a cheat
sheet you end up looking at that thing
and playing from the radar more than
you're actually paying attention to the
game yeah that's not in this game
ultimately I took it as because the tech
doesn't even exist yet so you get no
radar system that's otherwise known as
hard mode on every other Metal Gear
Solid game up to Snake Eater and I loved
that at first it was culture shock I was
like what the hell yeah you get this
little sonar thing that you click it's a
bang and then people hear it and they'll
come and kick your ass but the game
proves that people are very adaptable
you adapt so well to there not being a
radar system you end up peeking around
corners you end up being more careful in
Snake Eater you know like it's a real
mission and [ __ ] all you need are these
or this and if you remember my gripe
about Metal Gear Solid 2 is that when
you get seen the game's over they're
just going to kick your ass and kill you
Metal Gear Solid 3 that is ironed out
really well it focuses heavily on
camouflage it shows in the corner of
your screen how well you blend into your
surroundings you constantly have to
change your camouflage in your face
paint so if you get seen you can hide in
the shrubs there are a lot of places to
hide you can climb up into trees it's
easier to evade your enemies that and if
you want to fight them off you can fight
them off how often was I seen it I was
just like you know what I'm just gonna
take everyone out and I ended up wasting
everyone there were no more
reinforcements I liked that I felt like
if you got seen it wasn't instantly game
over because you're gonna die I love me
some solid gameplay Metal Gear Solid 3
has some solid gameplay and you now have
the option to like slice someone's neck
with your knife morbid but let me tell
you you do it a lot and the double
meaning of Snake Eater is that you eat
snakes among other animals it's not just
like in the other Metal Gear Solid games
it was a ration system it's like oh I'm
low on life rations fill up my life and
Snake Eater it's more of a stamina based
system you have stamina your stamina
drains if you get your ass kicked or
just over time you know you're running
around your stamina straining you need
to find snakes rabbits birds animals
goats whatever kill them eat them to
refill your stamina your stamina will
refill your life I thought that was
really cool it was innovative I love
that a lot more than the ration system
is just more involved that in the game
clocks itself so if you save the game
put it down for a couple of days come
back you look at all your food your
animals have gone rottens dead meat it
doesn't last too long so you got to toss
it and find new animals I thought that
was cool too and a lot of advancements
in this game there is a first aid system
if you start getting shot and sliced up
you'll notice your stamina is just
dropping
fast you need to go into your first aid
system take the bullets out with your
knife bandage yourself up you need to
heal yourself in snake eater when games
try to pull that off it's either really
annoying or really involved and cool I
thought it was involving cool I like the
system I like the overall system in
Metal Gear Solid 3 Snake Eater every
advancement they made in this game I
felt was perfection this is arguably my
favorite chapter in the Metal Gear Solid
series why because not only is the
gameplay fantastic but the story is so
good I mean your mentors defected to the
Soviet Union you have to kill her but
it's not that simple as no like oh
you're a traitor to the USA there are
logistics involved snake is really
attached to this chick it's not just
like a lover thing the fact that we're
never like that their combat buddies
they develop CQC which is the
close-quarter combat system you use in
the game they developed it together you
can tell they're really tight now he has
to kill her he's not gonna be able to do
that [ __ ] and it deals with perspective
of villains and heroes and the whole
theme of Metal Gear Solid is that there
are no heroes there are just people who
are normal people who get exaggerations
about them who get stories told about
them but in the end they're just human
beings the boss in this game tell snakes
she's like things change power shifts
today's enemy could be tomorrow's hero
or vice versa I mean as a soldier 10
years from now you're gonna be fighting
for a different cause because new people
will be in power who will have their
agenda and you'll have to fight for them
and when she's given these speeches
you're like huh I don't think big boss
is the bad guy we've been led to believe
all these years it looks like Kojima's
telling you more of big boss's story now
in the current game so I'm interested to
see where that [ __ ] goes all I can say
is Metal Gear Solid 3 gets you intrigued
for it and of course it taking place in
1964 you're going to see some of the
older characters in the other Metal Gear
Solid games who are in their prime in
their use namely arguably the coolest
character in the series Ocelot and he's
a complete wild card in this story I
mean in the other Metal Gear Solid games
he's a guy with a plan you know he knows
what he's doing and Snake Eater he is a
young dude with an ego he's like if Jim
Kirk used revolvers big Bazar does snake
rather humiliates the [ __ ] out of him so
he has a grudge against snake he wants
to kill him he wants to be the one to
kill him but you can tell throughout the
game he starts respecting snake as a
soldier it's really good I like it when
characters from opposing sides can
respect each other in stories and Snake
Eater does explain the Ocelot liquid arm
thing from Metal Gear Solid 2 you know
how he has liquid snakes arm and Metal
Gear Solid 2 and he gets possessed by
liquid snake and you're like that's
strange in this game and I don't think
it's a spoiler because the game
never actually comes out and tells you
this you gotta have to piece things
together and Hideo Kojima ended up
saying yet that's how it is but it's all
about ocelots father
ocelots father as a guy named the sorrow
the sorrow can commune with the dead
Ocelot being his son has that recessive
gene so when he got liquid snake's arm
liquid snake possesses him he's what the
hell in the world of Metal Gear Solid I
like the fact that they did explain that
it made sense and of course Metal Gear
Solid 3 Snake Eater has that boss flight
where I was like that is one of the
coolest boss fights in the entire series
and that is a guy named the end yeah all
the bosses in this games they're all
freaks and this game was actually the
one that made me go uh the bosses into
you aren't that crazy the end is this
old dude he's a sniper and you need to
get into a sniper fight you have to hunt
this guy down among three zones in the
game it doesn't show up on thermal
goggles all those footprints dude you
can cheat if you want to do that but
it's really fun to not use the thermal
goggles you've got to find this dude and
snipe him down
not only that there are ways to kill him
in which you don't even have to fight it
when you first see him before he gets
wheeled in his little wheelchair back
inside you can shoot him like either in
the head or blow up this barrel point is
you can kill him hours upon hours of
gameplay before the fight even happens
when you first meet the end he's dead
I thought that was cool and the dude is
so old that if you get to the end and
then put down the game for like seven
days or something like that just like
when your rations go bad you come back
the end has now died of old age simple
way to kill him I don't suggest doing
that because the sniper fight is so fun
I wouldn't want anyone to rob himself
with the experience of playing and
fighting the end gotta say that was one
cool fight just trying to find this guy
have a little directional mic you can
hear them breathe you can see the
twinkle of a sniper scope in the
distance course one of those things
really oh there he is and he was like
hey I saw you first and shoot you but
that boss fight man that's some legit
[ __ ] there is a scene in the game that I
mean as much as it is a torture scene
release an ass-kicking is one of my
favorite scenes in games there's a scene
where snake is just getting his ass
kicked I'm not just talking kick the bad
guy volgin is really just going to town
just beating the [ __ ] out of him but
this is big boss he's like the greatest
soldier ever so seen him so humanized
it's just you can't help but be like yes
this is a great saying it's just such a
relevant character moment that you got
to give your hat off to this game for it
I will say it does get annoying where
you're like okay this is the end of the
game right here you're fighting the boss
and that's not the end you got a
a little bit and flight another thing
really all right well well this is the
end of the game right no that's not the
end now you got to do this you've beaten
the entire game but you haven't beaten
the game because now you got a hall this
wounded person around and then you get
to the end and you're like this is then
not one more boss fight I mean I'm
telling you from the time you think all
right this is the last boss fight to
when you actually beat the game is like
three hours of gameplay it ends like
four times it's like bad boys too but a
lot better than bad boys too but that
bad boys too is terrible but Metal Gear
Solid shows a lot better than bad boys
do the only thing I would really change
about the game is nothing I would change
about the game it's actually the Vida
version of the game of course you
touched the back of the Vita it makes
snake lunges knife and it's annoying as
hell because your fingers rest their
Sony reps or anyone who's involved with
PS Vita technology if you're watching
this please come out with a patch in
which you can just shut off the touch
panel on the back of the PS Vita because
it gets annoying as hell so not only is
Metal Gear Solid 3 Snake Eater arguably
the best Metal Gear Solid in the Metal
Gear Solid series but it is a great game
one of my favorite games of all time and
it is up there and cinematic quality
with any Cold War spy epic you saying
I'm telling you the ending straight up
man tears Metal Gear Solid 3 Snake Eater
deals with honor betrayal loyalty where
things lie where the gray areas are if
you don't at least want to cry at the
end of this game I don't even know what
to say Metal Gear Solid 3 Snake Eater is
awesome tacular
I'd say pick up the Metal Gear Solid HD
collection for snake eater alone you
will get your money's worth out of it
and insertion for the Metal Gear Solid
theme I found this one chick there's
actually a couple chicks on YouTube who
played video game music with violins she
plays the Metal Gear Solid theme is
ultimately the Metal Gear Solid 2 theme
but I don't even carry put a link below
listen to it it's great it is beautiful
so hey check it out enjoy the [ __ ] out
of it and play Metal Gear Solid 3 Snake
Eater enjoy the [ __ ] out of that and of
course I'm gonna do Metal Gear Solid 4
and it might be after Resident Evil 6 oh
it might be a week or two out but I will
get that to you so many games for a
little time so your favorite Cold War
spy epic game book movie whatever what
is it comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more